-I was at the gynecologist
a couple months ago.
And I asked, "Is it safe
to have sex while I'm pregnant?"
And she was like,
"Yes, it is safe to have sex
through the whole pregnancy."
And I was like, "We'll be
seeking a second opinion."
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Amy Schumer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from your wonderful...
-Epic.
-...wonderful, epic new special,
"Growing."
-Thank you.
-And, obviously, this is a lot
about your pregnancy,
which you've been
very honest about,
and you're honest
in the special, as well.
Not an easy pregnancy
for you, physically.
-Yeah.
It's been pretty tough.
I didn't know that pregnancies
could be such a bummer.
You know?
-Yeah, well --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I really didn't know.
-You know they're hard,
but you've had, like,
some extra stuff
that's made it really rough.
-I have --
I still have hyperemesis.
I threw up a bunch of times
on my way here.
Worth it.
Love you guys so much.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-No, but I'm lucky.
I can, you know, get --
I have good healthcare.
-That's great.
-And I can get an I.V., and,
you know, survive.
-I'm very happy.
And do you guys know --
Do you know
what you're having yet?
-We do, but we don't care.
Like, you know,
however the baby identifies,
as long as they don't
identify as a deejay.
-Oh, yeah, that's fair.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause that's disgusting.
-No parent wants that.
-That's just disgusting.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-I know you talked
to my wife a great deal.
-Yep.
-Who's had two kids.
And, obviously, a lot of --
I would say,
probably a lot of mothers
give you advice,
both solicited and unsolicited.
Have you found that
to be the case?
-I think everyone's really
sensitive about giving advice.
Like, they're worried that
you've gotten too much advice.
-Yeah.
-So no one gives you advice.
You know?
I have to be like,
"No, I have no idea
what I'm doing,
and I would like some advice.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah,
actually, your wife --
she told me that prenatal yoga
really helps with the birth,
so I immediately
signed up for a C-section.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't -- 'Cause I'm not --
I'm not doing that.
I hate that.
-Yeah, why --
It would be a bad scene for you.
-I hate it.
-It's probably best
for the people
in the prenatal yoga class
not to have your energy.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
Everyone's like, "Why does it
feel so bad in here?"
And I'm just like...
Yeah.
-Your sister --
Really, this is incredible --
Made you a cake.
-My sister-in-law.
-Oh, your sister-in-law.
-I like to remind her
that it's just by law.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a very honest cake
about what
you're about to expect.
-Yeah.
-And I, you know --
Obviously, the idea
of giving someone
who's about to expect a baby
a cake is not that crazy,
but I don't think I've ever
seen this one before.
-No. That --
[ Laughter ]
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's not encouraging.
-No.
-I didn't feel encouraged.
And I just want to say, like,
I purposely
didn't have a baby shower.
-Yeah.
-It just --
It seems like a nightmare to me.
She came over at like
11:00 at night with that cake.
[ Laughter ]
Out of nowhere.
And I was like, "This is --"
That's Molly.
She's a bad person.
-Yeah, she's -- Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Bad.
-No, I've met Molly, yeah.
-Yeah, you know Molly.
She's the worst.
-Yeah, she's not great.
-Yeah, she's bad.
-That's a beautiful cake,
though.
-It's gorgeous.
-Yeah, she's a --
-And I did eat it.
Like, I ate it.
[ Laughter ]
I ate the ass [bleep]
Can I say the ass [bleep]?
-Yeah, you can say it.
-That's fine, right?
-As long as it's a cake ass
[bleep], you can say it.
If you said were eating --
-It's a cake's ass [bleep]
-If you were eating
a human ass [bleep]
we'd have to beep it,
but if you you're like,
"I ate the cake's ass [bleep]"
Yeah.
-No.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the law.
-That is the law.
You --
I'm so blown away.
I mean, obviously,
you are pregnant in the special.
And then you --
Obviously, you didn't write
and perform it just,
you also produced it
and directed it.
-Yeah. Real narcissist.
-Yeah.
-But, also,
that's a real burden of work.
Was there ever a time
you regretted doing that,
or were you happy
the whole way through
that you had
that control of this project?
-No, I was, like,
pretty terrified in thinking --
'Cause you have no control
over your body, you know?
-Right.
-It's just like --
Like, "Hope I don't
throw up all day
and have to be in the hospital."
And I did -- you know,
I taped two shows in Chicago.
I threw up in between a lot.
But, no, it just, like --
My body kind of held out.
-Did you feel, as a performer --
Did you feel that thing
of adrenaline kicking in
when you went on stage
and thinking, "All right.
This is gonna get me
through the hour"?
-Totally. Yes.
-Yeah.
-Same thing that's getting me
through this exact moment.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm here!
Yeah.
But everybody is giving me,
like, you know, advice,
but kind of
too late in the game.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah, like, it's --
Okay, I'm, like,
almost having this baby,
and just, like, yesterday,
my mom told me
that smoking increases the
chance of a low birth weight.
So, I had to,
like, just start smoking.
[ Laughter ]
-It might be too late now.
-I know.
And it's probably too late,
and I don't even like smoking.
It's very dangerous.
-Yeah, 'cause you probably --
It probably doesn't reduce it
if it hits
a certain weight already.
-Exactly. But here I am,
puffing away, just in case.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, better safe than sorry.
-Exactly.
-You don't want to have
a 10-pounder on the day.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-No.
I can't.
-And obviously,
you'd stop once it was born.
-But I'm getting hooked.
-Yeah.
-I'm getting hooked.
-Oh, okay, gotcha.
That's gonna make it harder.
-That's really good.
Like, I want young people
to see that.
[ Laughter ]